i've never done this
so hopefully it is a place
together all right and i'm gonna make a
lot of mistakes because
keyboard is not my forte so just enjoy
all of those okay it's jazz
first one out of the gate there we go
[Music]
let the king of my heart
be the mountain where i run
the fountains
[Music]
oh he is
let the king of my heart
be the wind inside myself
[Music]
is
you're good
[Music]
you're never
me down
[Music]
you're never gonna
you're
[Music]
you
[Applause]
oh
[Music]
[Applause]
you are
[Music]
you are never
you are good
[Music]
oh
cause you're the way maker
miracle worker promised keeper
light in the darkness my god
that is
in the darkness my god
that is who you are
sing that together you're the
we make a miracle work
[Music]
work promise keep light in the darkness
my god
[Music]
you were here
you are here
[Music]
you
i worship you
my god that is
[Music]
the darkness my god that is who you
are
[Music]
you you are here healing every life
healing every life
[Music]
i worship you
[Applause]
i worship
[Music]
[Applause]
my god that is who
[Music]
who you are that is who
you are
[Music]
oh
when i don't feel that
[Music]
even when i don't feel that you're
working
you never stop you never stop working
you never stop and never stop
you never stop working
[Music]
he's
right in the darkness my god
that is who you are
jesus thank you for the times that
you've been those things in our lives
and thank you for the times when we
don't
sense you or feel you or see
your movement or feel you're answering
our prayers but
know and can trust that you finish what
you begin
and that you complete a good work in our
lives god
we have all had moments when we have
felt that you are far away
and i'm so thankful that we can be
honest about those moments that we can
name them that we can say
i don't see or feel a god right now
but i can also look back and in
hindsight
see that you were doing a work in my
heart you were showing up in ways i
didn't even realize at the time
you were surrounding me with community
that loved me
you were bringing new relationships into
my life that had walked those paths
that had felt my pain and could show me
a new kind of love
you show up even in the places where we
don't feel you
even in the darkness when we cannot see
that you're there
i can believe and trust god that you are
still good
because you've never left me you've
never forsaken me
[Music]
and in the end of all things your love
wins your love goes beyond
all shame all pain all darkness
god
[Music]
i just want to take a moment for each
one of us
to just be still in quiet
um and just maybe even there are moments
that came to your mind
as we were singing that song um
or maybe just reflect and and see if
something does come up to your mind
where there's a place
where you have felt like there wasn't
room for you in the kingdom of god
where there wasn't a place for you at
his table
and i just want to invite god into that
space to rewrite that story for us
to show us a new version of the story
or to begin a new chapter where we begin
to walk
as children of god who are loved who are
accepted
who are seen and known
who can be at home in the person he
created us to be in a community
where we can bring ourselves and be a
part just as we are
so let's just take a moment and then
josh is going to sing come to the table
which i really feel embodies kind of the
values that we would like this community
to look like
so just have that space and then let's
just reflect on those words as we sing
[Music]
come
come to the table
[Music]
i'm out of the town
come
[Music]
every race every
to a table
to the table come and stay
come to the table
[Music]
the key
you're never a stranger
just come as you are
come behold
[Music]
come now
[Applause]
[Music]
there is a table
there's still more
[Applause]
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
jesus thank you that you welcome us to
your table thank you that there's room
for each person
each story in your kingdom god
we don't have to put on errors we don't
have to pretend
we come as we are and you meet us right
there
thank you for these people that we're
surrounded by thank you for the
friendships
and the family god be with us tonight
open our ears
and help us to hear you amen
thank you guys for worshiping with us if
you want to just
turn we won't do the whole like
everybody shake hands and get up and
move around
just yet but turn say hello
wave to a neighbor
all right y'all
here we are it's been a year easter was
you know
kind of i mean it counted we were we
were together but it was you know it was
different
and um and so to be here back in this
space
um is really really special and
meaningful
um for me and it's just great to be with
all of you
so thank you for being here i want to
welcome of course everyone
uh but especially if you are new uh it
can take a lot of courage to
walk through those doors and be like oh
gosh here i go
so um thank you for um having that
courage to
to step in and i also of course want to
again
welcome those online we love you all
and um consider you a part of the table
family
fully you know whether you're um even i
know like not everyone even who's online
is even like local
we have folks in other states and people
who are like tuning in which is
beautiful so
uh we love you and are so so grateful to
to have you with us
so uh the title of my message tonight is
the meeting the meeting and uh our text
is
it's actually going to consist of three
little small
stories kind of vignettes uh from john
chapter 20 verses 11
through 28 and um
you'll probably pick up on this but just
for context um because sometimes it can
be difficult when you just jump into a
random passage you're like
what is going on so um this is after the
crucifixion and even after the
resurrection
though um jesus has not yet appeared to
many of the disciples
and and things like that so it's sort of
post-resurrection but
people are still kind of figuring it out
um so all right john chapter 20 we'll
read through
uh the starting in verse 11. says
now mary stood outside of the tomb
crying and as she wept she bent over to
look into the tomb
and saw two angels in uh in white
seated where jesus body had been one at
the head the other at the foot
they asked her woman why are you crying
they have taken my lord away she said
and i don't know where they have put him
at this she turned around and saw jesus
standing there but she did not realize
that it was jesus
he asked her woman why are you crying
who is it you were looking for thinking
he was the gardener
she said sir if you've carried him away
tell me where you have put him and i
will get him
jesus said to her mary
she turned toward him and cried out in
aramaic
rabboni which means teacher
that's story number one here's story
number two on the evening of that first
day of the week
when the disciples were together with
the doors locked
for fear of the jewish leaders jesus
came and stood among them
and said peace be with you
after he had said this he showed him his
hands
and his side the disciples were
overjoyed when they saw the lord again
jesus said
peace be with you as the father has sent
me i am sending you
and with that he breathed on them and he
said
receive the holy spirit
skipping down a few verses to verse 24
this is story number three
now thomas also known as didymus one of
the twelve
was not with the disciples when jesus
came
so the other disciples told him we have
seen the lord
but he said to them unless i see the
nail marks in his hands
and put my finger where the nails were
and put my hand
into his side i will not believe
a week later his disciples were in the
house again and this time thomas was
with them
though the doors were locked jesus came
and stood among them
and said peace be with you
and then he said to thomas put your
finger here
see my hands and reach out put it into
my side
stop doubting and believe thomas said to
him
my lord and my god
now what i want you to notice tonight
in these these three stories uh
is the way that jesus met people
where they were not where
maybe jesus wish they were or where we
think well they should have been or they
should have had faith
like not where we think they should have
been where jesus you know had some stand
or something but the way jesus
met people where they were and then gave
them
the very gift that they needed
by gift i'm thinking you know of course
not like a birthday present clearly he's
not like handing out you know
things wrapped i'm talking of course
about um
you know words of encouragement um kind
of emotional relational
kind of soul needs you know he's he's
tuning in he's meeting them where they
are because again by even meeting them i
don't just mean
physically he's like showing up like hey
there i i mean he's meeting them in a
in like a presence kind of way you know
sometimes you can be somewhere and not
be there
um he's really there right so he's like
present and then he's tuning in and he's
giving them
the word the encouragement the faith
the hope the forgiveness the compassion
like whatever it is he's tuning into
what they need
and then he's giving it to them um
and and so i think this kind of this
meeting in this
giving kind of takes um or i see it
playing out in three ways which we'll
kind of unpack tonight um so the first
move that i see this happening this
meeting and giving happens from
of course as we just read from christ
and then it flows to
mary to the disciples to thomas
right um so let me unpack this a little
bit all right so starting with
mary um so i was kind of reflecting like
what was the gift
he gave her and i think it was of course
the gift of her name
did you catch that little moment where
she's you know a little bit
panicked like what is she getting
confused right she shows up to the tomb
it's empty
she's like oh my gosh should someone
take the body
so she's a little freaked out she sees
jesus she doesn't recognize him
and then he he says the one word that he
knew would
both confirm his identity
and yet also put her mind at ease
right he says her name it was the gift
of her name
uh to the 12 disciples i think it was um
pretty clearly the gift of of peace
so the text is pretty clear that there
they are
they're locked in a room uh which is
always a bad sign of course
anytime you're locking yourself in a
room it's like yeah things aren't good
so things are not going well for them
why because their leader had just been
crucified
and of course they're nervous as cats
like we might be next
uh because they're the famous followers
you know so
they're real nervous i also wonder that
the text doesn't say this
i do wonder if perhaps they're also a
little bit nervous
about jesus and here's what i mean um
they've probably heard rumors by now of
like the empty tomb
and you might think well oh come on it's
jesus he's so kind and loving and
wonderful and like yeah but we know like
all the stories i mean frankly the ones
we just read you know where he says
super kind and compassionate but they
don't know that all they know is that he
said
you this very night you all will fall
away from me if you were here at easter
you'll remember this part of the story
he predicts it like you all twelve will
follow me of course except peter who's
like oh won't and then he does three
times
right so so there so he told them you're
all gonna fall away and sure enough what
happens
they do they like well they're not there
for him they're not present they're
they're not defending him it's just they
fall away
he's crucified that's sort of it ends
terribly but then they start hearing
rumors
he's back right i mean we it's easy for
us to kind of look back
oh no that's wonderful news but i do i
wonder if they were
a little nervous again i am speculating
here the text doesn't say that
but i just i wonder so that they are
they're locked in this room
and suddenly who appears it's jesus
and then what's the very first word on
his
lips to these frightened
um failing men who maybe feared a little
bit like retribution what's the first
word
he says to them peace peace
be with you he tunes in to what they
need he says
the word that they needed they he gives
them the gift
that they needed finally of course we
have thomas
later in church history and really by
like
you know historians and church
theologians and such they remember him
as
um saint thomas and thomas he actually
went on to do
amazing things in the kingdom of god he
um history kind of has it that
he traveled to india to spread the good
news of jesus
like later in his life so he was like
awesome uh
but unfortunately kind of his brand his
reputation
you know in the kind of among most of us
we remember him
uh in fact we have a little nickname for
him do any of you know that
doubting thomas yeah that's kind of how
he's known poor guy it's like don't you
hate when you're like branded forever by
like
a bad week or two and that's just how
people remember you you know
doubting thomas oh there he is you know
he's like i went to india yeah so
so we don't we don't have good memories
of thomas but
this is a moment right and it is kind of
he's a skip he's kind of skeptical and
like i just don't know guys
uh this just seems out there so so what
happens jesus of course shows up
and and then i mean just immediately
um not only says you know peace with you
again kind of reiterating to all the
disciples
but then says go ahead thomas put your
put your fingers right here
go it's okay i mean just isn't that
beautiful
like just meeting thomas right where he
is and then giving him
the gift that that he needed
and you know i must admit that
uh i don't know i i probably wouldn't
have been so
gracious so kind if i were in jesus
place i do think i would have been super
nice to um to marry
because she was this is mary magdalene
by the way um not mary mother of jesus
uh and so because you know she's clearly
just kind of confused and like what is
the empty too
but you know the disciples as we touched
on they blew it
and so i don't know if i were jesus howl
just like you know oh no prob guys
uh i don't know if how i would have been
like and i in fact i came across a
sermon
uh some of you know richard rohr a
wonderful writer and a franciscan
catholic christian and he wrote he had a
whole sermon titled
what i would have said to the disciples
and uh
it wasn't nice things i jotted down a
few of his quotes
here they are you failures what kind of
men are you
the women were with me to the end why
should i ever
trust you again it's going to take a
long
time for us to rebuild our relationship
i love that that devil i think that
would have been
that would have been me way to go guys
and we got you know thomas over here is
like i'm just not sure only 11 of my
best friends you know like
come on thomas like and yet uh of course
this is not
at all how jesus responds is it and you
know i was reflecting
um the last few weeks it's not only like
literally the words that he says
like you know peace or mary it's it was
even
i think it was like his it was the
probably body language in the tone
right and and you know again like yes
how do you know brett are you
speculating here
well i'm basing this really on the
reactions the responses of the people
you know so you have mary who's kind of
freaked out and then what's her
exclamation you know her her response is
rabonai
teacher in fact it says the disciples
they go from completely freaked out
doors locked to the word is
overjoyed in other words i don't think
this was a
peace be with you i mean this how is he
saying this i think it was a heartfelt
peace peace be with you
right and then thomas again there's such
compassion in this
in this this giving this meeting in this
this giving
um in fact there's even a little moment
you might have caught it
it's kind of strange where jesus um
breathes
on them did you catch that moment which
probably strikes us as a little strange
like what is going on it was the moment
where he says receive the holy spirit
and then it says he breathes on them uh
and i get
that might sound you know a little bit
strange but i think there's actually
echoes here
of the book of genesis which is the very
first book in the bible if you'll
remember god
creates the first human being and then
does what
[Music]
breathes life into the human being
in fact the word in hebrew um is ruach
it means i mean even in the word you can
tell it means
wind breath spirit
he breathes life i mean what's he doing
there
he's he's he's breathing into this
into them this new life this new
humanity this fresh
hope i think that's again it just
communicates such a beautiful um kind of
posture uh and then of course there's
thomas
who again he doesn't berate he doesn't
shame
he just gently invites and just says
come here thomas
it's okay here feel the wounds that in
fact the word that came to mind
and this is i mean this in the old sense
is the word condescend
not in the modern sense that means like
you're condescending it means you have
this false sense of superiority and you
know you're a real jerk
um and the old meaning to condescend it
meant to
to go out um or to come down like the
idea was to go out to someone we even
have a phrase for this
we want to meet someone what halfway
i'll meet you half it's this sense of
going out or
coming down to the level and i think
that's exactly what jesus is doing
right he's he's like he's coming down to
thomas's level just meeting him
right where he's at it's a beautiful
picture isn't it it reminds me of um
like even maybe a grandparent like a
grandfather or a grandmother
who we see like playing with their you
know maybe a two-year-old or
three-year-old like grandchild
and they're like what are they doing
right they kind of get they stoop
literally down
right they get on their level and
they'll even like you know play a game
with them and when we see this happening
right and and maybe they'll even let
them win right and when we watch this
happening
we don't like look at them and say like
oh my gosh how could you lose to that
baby
right of course not we like we get it we
know
they're they're condescending they're
coming down to their level and that's
exactly what i see jesus doing so
beautifully
um here so that's the first move it goes
from christ
to mary to the disciples to thomas
second move
uh is from christ to me to us
you see i want to contend tonight that
this is not only what jesus
did but but this is what jesus
does he meets us
where we are at and gives us what we
need so i guess the question is what do
you
need what do you need
do you need some peace do you need some
encouragement
do you need some hope
some faith that you can like get through
the season
you're in do you need a fresh sense of
joy or life or love what what do you
need i believe
that jesus through the mystery of the
presence of the holy spirit
wants to meet you and give you
exactly what you need
but of course the gift doesn't stop
there does it it's not
life is not just about god give me what
i need
what else happens this is the third move
it goes
from from christ to us and them
from me to others
from me to others we might say it like
this jesus
meets me where i am and gives me what i
need
so that i can meet others and give them
what they need in other words in the way
that jesus comes down he condescends to
our level um in the same way
we then go out and meet others where
they
are um which leads me to a few questions
i'd like you to reflect on
uh where have i been refusing
um to meet others
where have i been refusing to give them
what they need now why do i phrase it
like this i don't um
at all mean to be kind of overly
negative but i do want us to be kind of
brutally honest with ourselves for a
moment
and here's the truth and i'll just this
is for me too um
we can at times be
so incredibly um bullheaded
and stubborn and um
and kind of have this sense that um
almost frustration with other people
that were like you know what either
come up to my level or meet me where i
am in other words i have some things
that i want to say
and i want to say him in the way that i
want to see him and i don't want to
tailor him to
you and you just right anyone and maybe
i'm alone in this
you know look give me some head nods if
you're tracking okay yes i'm not alone
okay that's good news
right or or sometimes it's not even
about words sometimes it's about actions
like i've got some things i want to do i
want to do it in the way that i want to
do it and i just want you to be able to
receive it i just need you
to be good with this please
right um and
this um i can speak from experience
this tends to go poorly um
not is it kind of only a generally
somewhat you know ineffective way to
move through life
but um at a whole other level i mean
obviously in light of the stories we've
been reading it's also
um quite unchrist-like because again
going back
to you know richard sermon what i would
have said right this is
this is clearly not what jesus did i
mean when he had every right people had
let him down
it led to his death i mean this is
extreme stuff and yet he just shows up
with such grace kindness
gentleness forgiveness
just beautiful i think that's calling us
up to something calling us somewhere
i had a little moment
uh with my daughter the other night i
got her permission to uh to share this
by the way
um and she is she's in sixth grade and
she's in the midst of just a difficult
homework transition maybe this always
happens in sixth grade i don't know but
the teachers have definitely
you know kind of made the transition
into look i'm not reminding you of
things anymore
if if it's not n then it's a zero
and um and so she's i mean she's and
she's incredibly bright she's you know
in
in hard classes and all the things but
there's just there's a growth curve here
you know and it's it's quite painful and
frustrating and
so we're we're sitting down the bar uh
this is um earlier in the week and
um our bar there in the kitchen not like
the chili's bar
we're just hanging out at the bar um at
the bar in our kitchen
and we're just sitting there and i got
the laptop open you know i got the
grades
up and we're just kind of going through
each you know assignment and just like
tracking
and um and it's a little rough
and you can just feel like the tension
growing between us and the like the
emotions you know just even though
nothing's being said yet
or all the words are just practical like
okay what about this thing but you can
just feel the emotion kind of
building and she's getting very
incredibly frustrated putting it mild
just you know hacked off in
and then i can just feel a torrent of
words
they're just right here y'all just right
there at my they haven't come out yet
but they're just building and i'm just
like
oh my gosh and it was probably um
only because in the previous about two
to three weeks i had already failed
about
five times at this precise moment as a
parent
that i like just praise the lord
i just tuned in you know to god and i
was like
okay and this is basically the thought
that just flashed through my mind again
it's god's grace
um the thought just flashed through my
mind brett
what does she need right now
and and then the thought flashed through
and
how do you say this in a way that she
can receive it
now um my wife maggie can tell you
all the stories about times that i
didn't
tune in in that way and empathize and
all that that will be after the service
you can have that conversation with her
just let me have this moment
so in this moment it went well you know
and basically what i did i just
i realized i didn't need to say anything
right then i just kind of reached my arm
back
and i just kind of like did that you
know just kind of scratch your back like
kind of
communicating like hey i'm here for you
and all of a sudden she just gets these
huge you know croco crocodile tears just
right there in the corners of her eyes
and she starts just communicating like
i've been trying so hard
i've you know just all of this it just
starts to pour out
and it was like in that moment suddenly
um god
christ was somehow present in the
meeting
and in the giving and
i get like that's a very small you know
little small moment
um but here's the thing um
your life and my life are nothing but a
billion small moments
and if we can learn
to tune into the presence of god
in those moments
christ is truly present with us
and then
god can begin to use us in powerful
beautiful ways and i just wonder and i'm
closing with this i just wonder
what would what would god do in in my
family in my relationship with my kids
if i could do that more often what could
god do if
you and your your little household or
your among your friendships or
um among this church community um
in your in your work in your school
wherever you're making a life
what would it mean what would it look
like for you to tune in
and meet people right where they are and
give them the gifts
the word of encouragement hope
life peace forgiveness
grace the very thing that they
need because here's the truth we all
want it in return don't we
we're like please just meet me where i
am you know
but i think god's message to us is yes
christ is doing that
he's meeting us where we are but then
we've got to turn around
and go and do likewise all right let me
pray for you
lord jesus
may you help us meet others where they
are god
so often um our pride
our fatigue our anger our frustration
it all just combines and god it just
holds us back
holds us back from from doing just that
from meeting
people where they are and giving them
what we need what they need and so god
we ask for your strength lord would you
breathe on us would you fill us with
your
spirit would you make us new and help us
radiate the light of your love to all
people for our own good and the good of
the entire
world it's in the powerful life-changing
name of jesus that i pray
amen
there we go all right you have to stand
up for this one
and i'm going to ask you to clap at a
certain point
and this is not very table-esque of us
okay
i know we're not we're a lot of
introverts let's just be frank
there's a lot of introverts in our
community we don't like a lot of
physicality and like
get outside your box but we're actually
going to do that tonight this is a new
song
what i love about it the guy who wrote
this song said i grew up
always feeling like i needed to strive
to the next level like even in church
coming to church like you put on your
best clothes
you know you want to get to that next
level at work whatever it is
and he said i never felt like i could be
proud of my blue collar job
or like my parents blue collar jobs like
we were just
you know average americans and i never
felt like we could come and celebrate
that
and i was like wow this is
a new thought for me and so i want us to
just end this song whatever it is
that you maybe feel like you could have
never been proud about
this is our moment to be real people who
take pride
in what god does in our lives and who he
made us to be
all right so at some point we're gonna
do this
okay when we get to that point even if
you're bad at rhythm just try
it's good to get out of our bodies i've
been in the garden like for like 17
weeks straight it feels like
and i can't tell you how good it is just
to move my body and
do things okay so this is our moment
this is our 17 weeks right here
all right let's do it
[Music]
we are
in our colors
[Music]
to be together again
we are now
[Music]
is
[Applause]
[Music]
let the people sing the songs of joy
let the rocks
again
[Music]
let the people sing the songs of joy
let the rocks cry out
[Applause]
[Music]
let the seas resound
let the people sing the songs of joy
all right let the rocks
let them
let the people sing the songs of joy one
more time
let the people sing the songs of joy
let the rocks drown
let the wind
[Music]
very nice very nice all right
don's gonna send us out here
you have to come up more excited than
that after that sun okay thank you
okay i will say i was actually
rhythmically challenged during that so
i appreciate that oh so anyway thank you
so much for everyone for uh coming out
and joining us this evening
especially those of you who are online
again we appreciate you you're very much
a part of our community
um and everything so i'm just a quick
reminder
um if you are um just haven't
if you're so led and i would like to
contribute to
the things that we do here at the table
uh you can actually go online and
there's a place where you can get uh
give financially
we appreciate that and then i'm just
gonna close this out real quick with a
quick prayer
lord uh just thank you so much um again
for just the ability to see each other
face to face
uh to be each other's physical presence
um being able to
be a part of this community and i pray
so much lord that you just help us to
see those things where we can give to
others this week
help us to be able to have the courage
to feel empowered
and then to be able to be like your son
and christian i pray amen
you